hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled advanced enzymes to
facilitate sars cov2 research this
webinar is part of the cell bio 2021 and
i am susie valdez of labyrinth and i
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by elaborates and sponsored by
thermo fisher for more information about
thermo fisher please go to
thermofisher.com
so let's get started before we begin i
want to remind everyone that this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
participate by first communicating with
other attendees using our new live chat
feature during the presentation you can
find this live chat feature located at
the right of your screen you can also
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send we will answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of our
presentation
finally this presentation has a survey
for you to participate in during this
live presentation and during the
on-demand period provided by our speaker
and located at the right of the abstract
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation click on the
help desk button located at the bottom
of your screen within the navigation bar
from the lobby and finally as a reminder
this presentation is educational and
offers free continuing education credits
click on the continuing education
credits link located in the abstract
window below the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain those
credits i now present today's speaker
leigh lavelle for complete biography
ugly please visit the biography tab at
the left of your screen we welcome you
may now begin your presentation
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar advanced enzymes to facilitate
sars kobe 2 research
i am jennifer woods of lab roots and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo fisher scientific to learn
more visit thermofisher.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting as many questions that you
may have during the presentation to do
so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please follow the process to obtain your
credits by clicking on the continuing
education credits window i'd like to now
welcome our speaker lee lavelle
senior product manager reverse
transcription at thermo fisher
scientific
lee you may now begin your presentation
thanks jennifer for the intro
hello everyone i appreciate you
attending this webinar
and i it's my pleasure to
share with you the information about
how
next-generation engineer enzymes were
used in the stars kobe 2 research
let's go ahead and start
due to collide pandemic a broad range of
interests have been triggered in
understanding the mechanism of the
buyers and identifying solutions to
address this global crisis
a lot of effort goes into the viral
research
virus detection prevention and the
treatment
for the viral research there are studies
focusing on genome transcriptome
characterization
pathogenesis mechanism virus evolution
and other aspects
the detection of south korea ii has
become the focus of research programs
there are also a number of initiatives
aiming for vaccine and antivirus
therapeutic development
now we come to our very first poll
question
i was thankful that you will take a
little bit time fill out this whole
question
okay let's continue
currently start kobe 2 virus research is
focused on three directions
according to
the technologies used
their target detection
high throughput sequencing and cloning
for targeted detection rtqpcr is the
gold standard
has been adopted by majority labs for
virus detection
the researchers also explore rtland
and the crispr based methods for point
care use
i'm going to share a little bit more
information about target detection in
the next few slides
for high throughput sequencing ngs is
the dominant method with flexible
strategies
for example the researchers can choose
to use
whole genome or targeted sequencing or
whole transcriptome analysis
other than that single molecule
long-range sequencing
such as nanopore sequencing also gained
popularity in virus research
i will share more in the later
slides
cloning has been used in many
applications that involve rtp cr senior
sequencing a number of the
number of cloning techniques
the current colway
19
pandemics present a severe a serious
public health crisis
and the better understanding of the
scope and spread the virus will be aided
by more widespread testing
here three different types of nuclear
acid testing
has been explored
so i will use this slide to give you
overview
the standard rtq pcr method is the
is
being wildly adopted by a lot of labs
case in the nasal swab or saliva samples
are collected and the viral particles
are inactivated and lysed
pediatricians and subsequent pcr
amplification are performed with either
a crude sample or purified rna targeting
specific regions of the virus genome for
detection
a popular alternative to rt qpcr is
isothermal amplification
which does not require thermal cycling
the major techniques are loop mediated
isothermal amplification lamp
i'm sure you have heard about this term
before and the recombinant polymerase
amplification rpa
length uses a strand depleting
displacing dna polymerase with
specifically designed nested primers
with complementary regions that form
hairpins to permit priming of subsequent
rounds of amplification
the same process repeat and repeat it
around the priming and strand extension
generate a mixture of stem loop and
cauliflower structured products
the release of hydrogen ions can be
detected using colometric ph indicator
dyes
the rpa uses a recombinase to catalyze
strand
invasion of primer into double-stranded
dna
single-stranded binding proteins are
included to stabilize the open duplex
structure
and the strand displacing dna polymerase
extends to primer
some researchers
and use both rpa and the lens
in a two-stage amplification
protocol to improve specificity and
sensitivity
the third category for is crispr-based
detection method a unique group of cast
nucleus such as cast-12 and cat13 were
discovered to possess dna or rna
cleavage activities
this feature has been exploited for
nucleic acid detection
the test non-specific
nucleus remains inactive until it binds
its program rna or dna target the
reporter molecules are cleaved releasing
a fluorescent dye from quencher
the right hand
graph shows the limit of detection
across different methods
you can see rtqpcr is still the most
sensitive method that's why the majority
testing
still
come from rtq pcr
other methods
can use to detect
as low as 10 molecules
okay
let's take a look at a second poll
question
this slide shows you
sars code 2 analysis workflow
it includes rna extraction from a number
from a variety of sample sources as
listed here
nasal swab and saliva samples are
the most common sarcoid ii samples
and researchers can pick environmental
samples blood samples and other type
samples to extract rna
the purified rna will be reverse
transcribed amplified that analyzed in
different ways based on the protocol
workflows some examples are
electrophoresis through real-time
fluorescence
or sequencing
starts code two
uh what i want to point out is in this
slide is sample preparation and enzyme
choice
are interconnected usually a good high
quality rna sample may only require
regular enzymes like mlv
reverse transcriptase or text dna
polymerase however
if degraded rna samples or low input rna
is used a better enzyme is required in
this case because the battery enzymes
help deal rna or dna targets of sub
sub-optimal
purity and abundance
stars called 2 has enlarged has emerged
in 2019 and has rapidly spread worldwide
it is a positive sense single-stranded
rna virus with five caps and three poly
a tail
it's the longest rna virus about 30
kilobases
the clinical viral samples are easily
degraded during transportation and rna
extraction
other challenges include long testing
time
and multiplexing challenges
a number of features should take
consideration when you select the enzyme
region to
study starcov2 virus
the preferable feature of the enzyme
include
high processivity faster speed better
specificity
accuracy and ability to multiplex should
be considered for
circle 2 research here i just want to
point out processivity is defined as
the number of nucleotides incorporated
during a binding event
for example
the wild-type mlv reverse transcriptase
can incorporate city nucleotides
in one binding event with engineer next
generation enzymes such as super screen
four
the incorporation number much higher it
could accomplish 1500
nucleotides
in cooperation in one binding event so
the processivity is much higher
and this can be translated into the high
speed
so some next generation enzyme examples
listed here
for the reverse transcriptase
superscript four reagents
they're all pretty good candidate for
study to start co-2
research
and for the
in dna polymerase platinum super two dna
polymerase currently has the highest
fidelity is a three hundred fold more
fidelity than any uh current high cedar
dna polymerase on the market high
fidelity is very important essential
feature to be used for cloning
applications and sequencing applications
okay now we can zoom in
to talk a little bit more about viral
target amplifications i'm going to share
two methods rtqpcr
and rtlan
and the featured regions are listed here
is superscript3 one staff and super
square four also bsd dna polymerase i'm
going to share a number of publications
recommend a number of rtqp cell
protocols for start cover 2 detection
this protocol
using super 3 3 and phantom tag is one
of them
following the recommendation a german
group tested this protocol
and purified rna samples
amplified using one step
rt qpcr with gene-specific primers
targeting rdrp and egenes their specific
signals were significantly
reduced in the superscript 3 one step
setup compared to quantity tag another
rd enzyme which used as a reference
this protocol is demonstrated to be a
fast and sensitive protocol for virus
detection
the protocol can be
done
can be downloaded on who website
i listed a link on the bottom of this
slide for your reference
in an effort
to block the white of the widespread
transmission starts covering two wires
researchers from georgia state
university tested the efficacy of drug
compound
mk4482
eidd 2801 against stars pro 2 infection
in ferret models this compound has shown
potent anti-inflammatory virus activity
in the clinical trials
viral administration of the drug
compound exhibited reduction of virus
load in upper respiratory tract and
successfully block community
transmission
rtq-pcr was used to detect the virus
load
with purified from either harvest organs
or
pvmc
samples in addition
the systematic interferon and cytokine
expression profiling is performed with
the real-time cyberbrain and essay
now i would like to spend a little bit
time to compare the differences between
the gold standard detection method
rtqpcr and rtlan
rtqpcr method requires trained personnel
and fully equipped lab facilities
rtlam is a more simplified method easy
to use no special equipment needed
it takes shorter time to generate
results compared to rt qpcr
however rt lamp has lower sensitivity
and specificity than rt qpcr
recently we published an application
note detailing and optimized rt-lamp
protocol
this slide shows the simplified rtlam
protocol workflow designed by us for
rapid detection of start code 2.
this protocol does not require a new
region
all the regions used in this protocol
our existing region can be ordered on
our website it also provides template to
test the protocol for additional targets
with other primer sets
the protocol the protocol starts with
magmax purified rna samples all the
components are combined together to
prepare reaction mix
direction mix include bsm dna polymerase
superscript 4 reverse transcriptase rna
template and specifically design the six
primers
after mixing all the components together
and the protocol goes through the
incubation and inactivation steps
finally several endpoint methods to
visualize the results are demonstrated
such as direct color visualization show
on the picture a
and aggro gel shown picture b
so you can see the stars cover two
positive samples and show that different
target band from the lane one to line
five
and the korean there's a ukraine
uh korean group
and they actually looking at develop
their own version of
lamp
rt lamp the design evaluation rtlam axis
for detection start code 2 with a
limited of detection of 100 copies
per reaction
so they actually
extracted rna
from a cultural medium of
the cytocova-2 infected cells
and superscript 4 reversion scriptures
with bsc dna polymerase and used for cdn
synthesis and amplification
and the visual
calories color matrix
visualization can be performed
as shown in the graph on the right hand
side you can see
is this message sensitive enough can
only detect color change with source
code too
in no or no template control and some
similar
and virus sequences and you don't see
the color change
so the visualization this the detection
can be also performed with re raise rt
qpcr method
now let's take a look at
the deep sequencing for virus detection
research
um we are switchgear to take a look at
um ngs method and nanopore sequencing
and other sequencing methods the super
spray 4 reverse transcript is typically
used for this type of applications on
goal we are going to look at a number of
applications
each sequencing plays a critical role in
stars kobe 2 research it offers single
base sensitivity to investigate a virus
variant
there's no prior sequence knowledge
required compared to pcr-based methods
it's also a common method to study host
pathogen interactions with complete and
high coverage
researchers can choose whole genome
sequencing or targeted sequencing ngs or
single molecule sequencing
the scales of the studies can be large
or small
australia researchers analyzed
over two transmission pathways in
australia by south korea genome
sequencing this publication happened
a few m a few months after the global
pandemic happens
so they want to identify which portion
actually locally acquired which portion
of cases actually imported from overseas
the collective clinical samples
collected on the clinical samples with
positive rtb cell results these samples
were reversed transcribed using
superscript 4 willow master mix the
viral cdnas were amplified by multiplex
pcr with plentium superfly pcr master
mix amplicons were then pulled purified
and quantified followed by library prep
using extra xt library preparation kit
only a quarter of a sequence cases
appear to be locally acquired this
high-resolution genomic data are crucial
to take
cases with locally acquired kovi 19 and
overseas
importation
how do we decide if the enrichment is
needed for sequencing
so this really depends on research goal
if the purpose to is just focused on the
viral genome the viral genome needs to
be enraged by either amplification based
on hybridization
or amplification method the overall
sequencing cost will be reduced
the majority reads would map to the
south cova2 genome
however if the research goal is to
analyze host pathogen interactions
no enrichment will be required
you will gain a whole picture with reads
covering a variety of different
different genomes with human genome over
70 percent and less than three percent
of reads mapped to start cov2 genome
we developed an optimized workflow for
sequencing the sarcobate 2 genome
you may download it from our website
of the downloads the app notes from our
website
this application this application node
details the protocol starting from rna
purification
total rna was extracted from bal
clinical specimen
the applied biosystem magmax viral
nuclei acid
isolation kit was used for purification
super sugar 4 velo master mix and
thermal scientific second strand cd
intensive kit was used for
cdna synthesis the sequencing ready
library was prepared with cleavery and
the enzymatic sharing dna library
preparation kit with unique dual indexes
the library were pulled and raised using
a synthetic probe panel by pcr
amplification
the step is option this step is optional
the final concentration the libraries
were quantified
with clippery library quantification kit
then sequence on the illumina system
here at least
the time takes for each step so the
entire workflow may take one to two days
um so this is a nice study published on
sale
and the last year the crane researchers
they established
a high resolution sharp kobe 2
transcriptone map
and they actually used to
match their sequence they used two
sequencing method
to do this to do the study
and one is
um
one is the
ngs
sequencing by things is
like illumina or mgi system
and they used uh
they used the nano pro base to direct
the rna sequencing
for the rest of uh for the rest of the
studies
so they started total rna actually
purified from the virus infected
virus-infected cells
and the viral cdna thinks is using
superscript 4 rt
enzyme followed by the pcr amplification
and gel
purification
and then they will perform
the
individual transcriptome
and they were able to follow the
the manufacturing protocol to perform
direct rna sequencing library
and using superscript 4 rt enzyme
this is a two arm approach
using two different
sequencing system to verify the data
so what they found is their numerous
discontinuous transcriptome events
at least the 41
potential rna modification sites were
identified
stars poverty 2 also produces rna
encoding unknown open reading frames
first
so this is a really nice study to map
out the entire transcription map
so this study
showing the recently
we see that
there's new
varying strain and called
b117 variant and the first item by the
uk kingdom
and everyone knows about this stream is
really have a high profile on the medium
everybody report about it and they had
gained a strong
for foothold around the world
and in december in california first and
the researchers identified this uh
and this is the virus and they collected
a number of
clinical samples and those samples
already verified with
rt2pcr as positive samples and from
there they will
end using both rna sequencing and
rtqpcr to method to confirm the b117
variant
and they are they show the bb1 b117
rapidly become the dominant star kobe 2
variant in the us us will share the
similar trajectory as
um the
other country where the be
the news variant b117 is spread
so this study shows uh another way to
and analyze the
the stars cov2 with ngs
so currently when the patients show the
symptom they get
detected to show the positive negative
so the early
detection using rtqpcr is the only way
to predict viral load even though there
are some patients with no symptoms
this is the imperfect
readout in this case
so group researchers from national
university of singapore they
determined to identify a better
predictor of the viral load they
developed the viral long
fragment
for this is based on the sequencing and
sequencing of the viral lung segment
first of all dna are
rna purified from nasal saliva samples
and they
the reverse transcription performed
using applied biosystem high capacity
and reverse transcriptase
and amplified
by the multiplexing pcr using plantium
superphyto dna polymerase
the library
is prepared
following the
the regular protocol and
and then the illumina system was used
and paradigm 2 by 150 base pair
sequencing was performed
and then they proved that ngs actually
indeed a very sensitive method to detect
long rna fragments
the bond is a long fragment
and the score is positively
uh associated with wider load and the
inversely
associated with
the time
from the disease onsite in another word
the longer the disease has been
diagnosed the score the viral long
fragment score will be lower
so they designed the primers for 327
amplicon
and with
155 stars covered two positive samples
okay so after sharing two technology in
lessons so we're scared to take a look
at cloning so cloning typically involved
rt pcr and different cloning technique
and the senior sequencing so the popular
product used for the cloning
applications include superscript four
one staff and first strand synthesis
systems plentium superfly two dna
polymer is another popular
option
because of its high fidelity
okay here's our
post question i appreciate you answer
that question let's
wait here for a little bit
now we move to another
publication
a german
um
you know a group
a group from
the university of texas they actually
developed this method called isa and
this will reverse the established
reverse genetic
of coronal virus by infectious sub
genomic amplifi amplicons method
so this method
has been developed in recent years on
focus on the short
single strand
rna
genome and this is the first
publications
they established and the
the first publications established on
the long
rna strand
so the researchers
and they
use this technology and in
with a purpose no in need for
constructing a full genomic cdna
mutations
and fluorescent reporter genes were
incorporated in this case
so first of all they designed
and eight overlapping denoble synthetic
viral fragments
uh you they use
this fragment as a template to
synthesize cdna using super screen for
one step rdpcr system
then the cdna
were amplified with super phi
2 dna polymerase
and this amplified for fragments
were
transfected into cells
the fluence recombinant viral genome was
produced within the cell through the
invaluable dna combination
the fullness viral genome were then
verified by one step
rtp crsa
the constructed genome
it turned out is completely identical to
that or targeted virus
the rescued virus replicates the
phenotypic and genotypic characteristic
of original isolate
university of uh
university researchers developed a re
develop a
another reverse genetic system
to study south korea to virus
the viral rna purified from viral e6
cells were used as a template for rtpcr
to produce cdna fragments
their seven cdn fragments were
constructed to overlap the entire
the viral genome
so the four of them are chemically
synthesized
three of them went through the
traditional cloning process because
those three fragments not stable
by the chemical synthesis
so the cdna was re was synthesized using
super screen 4 first strand obsidian
synthesis kit
and then amplified using superfight 2
polymerase all cds fragments are
individually cloned
the rna turns right from the full-length
cdas were highly infectious exhibited
similar
plague morphology viral rna profile and
replication kinetics
and in addition this system generates
stable reporter genes and can be used to
evaluate the antivirus activities
potential therapeutic
so it turned out to be a really valuable
system for the drug screening process
the german group analyzed antibody
response of 12 kobe 19 patients from 8
to 69 days after diagnosis
the neutralizing antibodies showed a
broad spectrum of variable genes and a
low-level somatic mutation
this demonstrates
dark co2
neutralizing
antibodies
are readily generated from a diverse
pool of precursors
and giving us the hope for rapid
induction of a protected immune response
upon vaccination
in this study sarcophagu active
domain-specific b-cells were isolated
from pbmcs single-cell amplification
antibody having light chains was
performed using super screen 4.
reverse for reverse transcription plenty
attack hot start polymerase for
amplification
the pcr products were then analyzed by
gel electrophoresis followed by single
sequencing
so lastly
and
i would like to share
with you about the benefits like ready
enzyme formulation
it requires
in a process called lyophilization
this is a water removal process used to
preserve perishable materials to extend
shelf life or make the material more
convenient for transport
drug and diagnostic acid developers
their interest in this process
however the conventional formulation
enzyme contains up to 50 glycerol
which stabilizes
stabilizes enzymes but interferes with
leo fertilization process
a good lyric enzyme should be formulated
with glycerol content levels well below
0.5
in the meantime
maintain equivalent performance of
reproducibility sensitivity and
specificity
to the com
compared to the conventional formulation
okay let's pause here for our last four
questions
so when considering
a lion ready enzyme for nuclear acid
amplification there are three different
categories you can consider one is
performance
here at least the different performance
important
is inhibitor tolerance thermal stability
processivities but specificity low
residual dna contamination
and in terms of consistency
you would like to take the bioready
enzyme
and have very similar
good qc tests from batch to batch and
minimize any variation introduced from
the different badges
and the quality will be good to take
from the facility iso certified facility
high quality facility to manufacturing
like already enzymes
okay this concludes my presentation
today
i appreciate any questions you may bring
up
thank you
okay here is our last question
last poll question
thank you for your attention
thank you lee for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you would like to ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
let's get started
our first question is
what's the multiplex capacity of the
platinum superfine dna polymerase and
how does universal annealing temperature
work
that's a very good question actually
there's no limitation with the enzyme
itself in terms of how many multiplex
reactions can be incorporated
is can be used for many many targets in
one reaction the limitation factor
actually from the different components
it really is combination of how much
primers in one reaction
and what's the other component that's
the limiting factors the more on the
more
interaction in inc put together in one
reaction the more enzyme the more
primers and the more um buffered
everything has to be optimized but the
enzyme itself can accommodate as many
reactions as possible
and in terms of universal
temperature that's a really really good
feature we have with superfine
to
polymerase as well as
plantium
pack heart start enzyme so we have this
innovation to optimize
the buffer condition
so in the past it's very inconvenient
when designing the different primer sets
and how to optimize the melting
temperature
to is
to a similar level so making the
kneeling temperature is more or less the
same but with the current formulation
and you can design the whatever primers
you need it without worrying about a
similar
the annealing temperature you can just
throw all your primer sets together and
then the buffer condition will take care
of that they will be able to
use the universal condition to carry out
the reaction hopefully i answer your
question
thank you lee our next question here is
for detection of the covavirus what's
your thought on using purified rna
versus adding samples directly to the rt
reaction
that's another good question
initially when the research developed
the detection method workflow always
start with purified rnas there are some
limiting factors with the global
pandemics the more and more
need for widespread nuclear acid testing
there is not enough the rna purification
kit that's become bottleneck i see that
there is a significant slow down the
diagnosis process because of the
limitation from the rna library
preparation kit
and so there is a more and more
researchers think about alternative
solution which is how about we skipped
rna purification just like
the samples and directly carried out to
the rtq pcr or rtlm this is a good
concept which is being studied a lot the
um the con for this method actually is
the
compatibility between
the transportation medium as you know
those clinical samples lava or the nasal
swab need to put in the transportation
medium transfer to the lab and then
and process for the next step if the
transporter medium not compatible with
super straight
superscript or reverse transcriptions in
general and that's a great problem
and there's uh some
considerations like
sensitivities and
different background noise also need to
consider but in general in direct
approach using crude samples will be
faster more straightforward and can
bypass that
and bottleneck from the rna isolation
kit
supply issues
okay great thank you so much lee and our
next question here is
can you please elaborate more on
processes processivity
yeah processivity is
as i mentioned in the presentation is
defined as the number of nucleotides
cooperated in a single binding event
so the wild type typically have 30 to 50
nucleotides incorporated in one binding
event you can imagine when they
cooperate low number of nucleotides it
takes longer time to finish the cdn
synthesis and using
reverse transcriptions as an example
and for the engineered enzyme at
superscoring four is much faster it can
incorporate as many nucleotides as
possible so far we see that 1 500
nucleotides and there's a 500 fold
difference basically between the wild
type and the engineered enzyme so the
advantage of this as i mentioned earlier
is fat right it's just moving really
fast it takes only 10 minutes to reverse
transcription compared to
the wild
rt enzyme and also it can translate to
how we can overcome the rt inhibitors in
the reaction mix typically with a slow
lower processivity enzyme when there is
some inheritance or introduced
the inhibitors in the reaction
the rt enzyme will typica the
traditional rtns will slow down
and would not be able to finish the
synthesis of a full-length cdna but with
high processivity enzyme it will be
overcome the any inhibitors or
sub-optimal rna qualities
they overcome that issue still get
pretty decent cdna thinks is results
yeah that's a really big benefit for the
next generation enzyme
right thank you lee and we have time for
one more question
how do i decide which workflows i should
use one-step rt-pcr or two-step rt-pcr
so one-step rt-pcr is a fact
convenient can be avoided
and be used to minimize the potential
contamination introduced by two stack
because there's more pipetting steps
involved
and that's the advantage using one step
rtpr
in this case the gene-specific primer
required and so the knowledge about
the genome or about sequences is needed
and so this one-step rtpcr very
extremely popular and necessary for the
detection gene detection world for
diagnosing the quick
and um
simple to resolve world so typically one
step rtpcr is used to detect
or to detect a virus but for the
research world in one step rtpcr there's
lack of flexibility and researchers
cannot optimize
the conditions everything already added
in one tube and there's a limited power
for them to
optimize their assets so two-step rtpcr
system will be really
um
orbiting typically used
was typically used by the researchers in
the lab
and like sequencing projects or any new
method to develop you typically use two
too much two methods you could use
random primers and oligodt to basically
synthesize the cdna
across the board and then pick the
gene-specific primers to amplify
for the second step
yeah hopefully i have answered your
question
thank you lee
do you have any final comments for our
audience today
i want to thank you everyone to spend
time
with me and to going over this older
publications what enzyme can be used to
accomplish what purposes i'm sure this
short presentation cannot cover every
single aspect of the covet research with
this center stage our daily life
which is profoundly impact all of us and
i i want to first of all thank all the
researchers and
and to
in-depth in this effort to overcome this
pandemic provide a solution for us for
all of us and also we are so proud to
provide solutions raising solutions to
help the researchers we definitely have
large
selection of different enzymes we are
well known for the high quality dna
polymerase and
the our reverse transcriptase so
please check out our website to see what
enzyme will meet your needs and
and will be happy to provide any
solutions if you have any questions
would be happy to answer and
please contact our sales team for any
questions you have
thank you again lee for your time today
and for your important research
we would also like to thank labrus and
our sponsor thermo fisher scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time goodbye